[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 15 septembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60 18 20 minutes
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les titres de cette édition un
véritable casse tête en pleine épidémie
de kovy 19 comment servir des repas en
cantine tout en respectant les mesures
sanitaires la restauration collective
doit s'adapter voir se réinventer dans
ce contexte
reportage dans une école de magny les
hameaux la firme de la tramblais à la
boissière école accueillait le week-end
dernier la première édition du pari
fermier environ 50 producteurs étaient
présents à l'occasion de dresser le
bilan de l'impact sur l'eau du
coronavirus sur le monde de
l'agriculture
enfin la page dédiée à la législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour au programme
dimanche 20 septembre avec onze
candidats olivier galland est notre
invité il est en lice pour debout la
france
et puis à suivre aussi cette journée a
découvertes proposées par le club des
templiers à del en course et du football
américain
[Musique]
à l'école ou en entreprise le qu'ovide
19 a forcément changé les habitudes au
sein de la cantine protocole sanitaire
oblige mais la restauration collective
c'est aussi se réinventer comme vous
allez voir avec ce sujet d'eléonore
sinoquet en file indienne les enfants de
l'école louise reis a là ni les âmes
attendent patiemment leur tour pour
entrer dans la cantine avec la crise
sanitaire la restauration collective a
dû s'adapter et à plus d'audace
désaffection obligé en fait attention en
maths on porte le masque
gestes-barrières l'étape sont
désinfectés les chaises aussi tout ce
que les enfants peuvent toucher on
remédie à ce que à ce que ce soit des
infectés à chaque fois à chaque passage
donc c'est vrai que c'est un travail
mais il faut le faire parce que c'est
pour le bien et la santé tout le monde
si les consignes sanitaires
gouvernementales sont respectés la
restauration collective et c'est
également de se réinvente le made in
france alimentation plus saine gestion
des déchets des changements vers une
cantine 2.0 qui n'ont pas été freiné par
l'aco vide à magny les hameaux
la crise sanitaire
justifie finalement ce qu'on avait déjà
engagés auparavant avec plus de bio plus
plus d'action / sur la gestion du zéro
déchet et puis plus d'action aussi vers
vers le local et des produits locaux
tout ça donc on l'imaginait auparavant
on avait déjà entamé un certain nombre
d'actions
aujourd'hui très clairement on sait
quelle est la marche à suivre
les sociétés de restauration collective
et c'est aussi de s'adapter à la crise
elior par exemple qui possède un
restaurant d'entreprise à montigny le
bretonneux a développé le fameux click
and collect ou encore le self qui
s'emporte des tendances qui devraient
perdurer à l'avenir le colis de 19 ans
impact est également le monde de
l'agriculture peu ou pas de main
d'oeuvre pendant le confinement en
baisse du chiffre d'affaires elle nous
avons tenté de dresser le bilan avec les
exploitants une cinquantaine étaient ce
week end au pari fermier à la boissière
école à la première édition de cet
événement était organisé par la ferme du
tremblay marie pas neutre à paul
reportage
la ferme de la tramblais a perdu 25% de
son chiffre d'affaires pendant le
confinement
alors qu'elle constatait un engouement
pour la consommation locale il y a
quelques mois
l'équipe a un objectif ne pas se faire
oublier
pour cela elle a notamment accueilli le
paris fermant consommer local fermiers
éventuellement bio c'est une action de
chacun et donc c'est chaque consommateur
qui viendra se rendre sur ce type
d'événement qui ravoir son producteur
local qui ce qui fera une action qui
fera en sorte que ce type de marché
continue de son histoire combler l'écart
avec ces chiffres de l'année dernière
pour son voisin de stand un viticulteur
les pertes sont considérables 60 à 70%
du chiffre d'affaires en moins pendant
le confinement
mais aujourd'hui l'heure est à
l'optimisme depuis le 11 mai il y à une
forte affluence dans ses caves de
pouvoir être là et dire aux gens banon
la vie continue il faut que la vie
continue il faut que les clients se
déplacent
il faut que les producteurs se déplace
il faut pas qu'on cède à la halle à
beurre et cetera il faut qu'on soit
prudent effectivement il faut que les
gestes barrières soient respectés
la vie continue et certains producteurs
voient leurs efforts pendant le
confinement récompensé 30% de la
nouvelle clientèle de ce maraîcher
continuent d'acheter sur les marchés ce
qu'on peut en ressentir ou a toujours
autant de monde
par contre avec une volonté de retrouver
du producteur local donc on a augmenté
un petit peu nos paniers en fait sur les
sur les marchés on sent les gens plus
proche de revenir un peu vers les
producteurs le mot d'ordre de cet
événement soutenez-nous près de 5000
personnes se sont déplacées au premier
pari fermier à la rentrée pour le
conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la séance se
dérouler jeudi à 10 septembre à trappes
après avoir choisi aller vice président
de la collectivité en juillet au
vélodrome les élus étaient de retour
dans la salle du commune du conseil
communautaire elle est est aménagée
spécialement pour l'occasion dans le
respect des règles sanitaires alors de
ce conseil les différentes commissions
étaient composées toujours dans une
volonté d'ouverture vers les douze
communes du territoire
le président jean michel fourgous a été
interrogée par mélanie poker dans la
mesure où ici c'est d'une
intercommunalité très économique
faut pas se leurrer
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mans donc
c'est pas dégeu politique c'est pas
l'assemblée nationale mon appartement où
chacun vous apporter une valeur ajoutée
en termes de compréhension l'économie de
l'emploi de produire de la richesse
c'est à dire quand on produit la
richesse en produits le social les élus
sont dans cet état d'esprit
écoutez il faut il faut bien sûr
redistribuer le plus possible où il ya
comme une majorité il soin de redire
mais il demeure que tout le monde toutes
les communes de gauche comme de droite
ont une délégation et c'est pas une
délégation de témoignages
[Musique]
le sport avec cette décision rendue
officielle aujourd'hui l'eco-trail 2020
de paris édifie nitivement annulé à la
course prévue initialement en mars avait
été reportée en oui au week-end du 3 et
4 octobre soit n'aura finalement pas
lieu
elle les obstacles étaient devenus trop
nombreux et l'incertitude grandissante
ont justifié les organisateurs dans un
communiqué l'eco trail devait s'élancer
de l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le 80 km et du château de
versailles pour le 45 km est les
inscrits peuvent recevoir un avoir pour
participer aux éditions 2021 et 2022 ou
être remboursés à hauteur de 50% des
droits d'inscription est les templiers
d'elancourt reprennent du service le
club de football américain a débuté
l'entraînement la semaine dernière et
pour bien lancer leur saison
elle les joueurs et l'encours toi
proposer une journée découverte dimanche
dernier au complexe de l'europe
astrid bergère étaient sur place le
football américain est méconnu du grand
public et fait parfois l'objet de
fausses idées pour y remédier pour cette
nouvelle saison les templiers
d'elancourt ont organisé une journée de
découverte le but en fait c'est de faire
découvrir en fait ce sport faire
découvrir les opportunités qu'on
pourrait retrouver en faisant ce sport
pour dire aux gens que si vous venez ici
c'est que vous êtes motivés pour pour
faire les efforts qu'il faut pour
pour adhérer à l'équipe pendant la
journée les intéressés ont participé à
une réunion un échauffement en salle et
une découverte des différents postes sur
le terrain le club a tenté de faire
comprendre que chacun avait sa place
le football américain c'est ouvert à
tout le monde qu'on soit grand petit
gros ou minces c'est vraiment en fait on
va utiliser la force de la personne pour
le bien de l'équipe
ces échanges ont aussi été l'occasion de
rappeler les règles du sport un moyen de
rassurer les parents comme celle de
quentin c'est vrai qu'en tant par chobo
l'américain on prend ce qu'on pense la
physique je suis dit que le foot que le
soccer comme ils disent et du coup et on
attend de nous aussi d'être assurée dans
les règles j'ai cru comprendre que les
chocs étaient un peu bannie il est
possible d'intégrer les templiers dès 14
ans ils ont engagé cette année un
préparateur physique
une arrivée bénéfique pour tous les
clubs toujours à elancourt la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
a lancé sa saison culturelle 2020-2021
c'était samedi dernier lors d'une soirée
avec plusieurs temps forts des temps
forts qui vont aussi animé l'année à
commencer par les journées européennes
du patrimoine qui arrive ce week end
présentation de la saison avec bixente
n'a rien senti steban et nicolas landry
un visuel spectacle de danse poésie
expériences scientifiques
quatre axes du programme culturel de la
commanderie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mise en avant lors de la soirée
d'inauguration ce lieu incarne à la fois
une dimension historique importante
c'est un lieu emblématique pour
l'agglomération et en même temps il se
veut
accompagné l'émission culturelle pour la
saison qui s'annonce c'est un espèce de
lieux privilégiés à part dans la ville
sur le territoire on laisse quasiment le
décor extérieur à l'extérieur et on est
dans un autre lieu carew d'art et ça
c'est magique et c'est rare une soirée
d'inauguration point de départ d'une
saison qui s'annonce riche
les moments forts le premier qui me
vient à l'idée ce sera les journées de
la science importante très importante
parce que là la mission science et est
importante notamment pour pour les
enfants et puis l'autre événement un
autre événement de grande convivialité
qui sera le noël des cas les voilà au
mois de décembre
en attendant c'est un moment chaleureux
et festif qui a été proposé aux saint
quentinois 450 personnes ont répondu
présent à l'appel malgré les
restrictions sanitaires en vigueur
là encore à saint quentin en yvelines la
culture entre en résistance face au co
ville les espaces se sont remplis les
publics vont et viennent donc on est
très heureux il y à tous les âges sont
représentés
donc c'était vraiment notre ambition de
pouvoir réunir les familles et puis
toutes les générations
prochain rendez vous les journées
européennes du patrimoine les 19 et 27
ans est d'ailleurs la saison du 7-8
culture est lancée aussi ce soir sur tv
78 le monde culturel et qui se poursuit
malgré le contexte actuel justin brasier
vous donnera le programme des prochains
jours dans le département le 7-8 culture
c'est à retrouver à 18h30
[Musique]
pour terminer ce journal la page dédiée
aux élections législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription des yvelines
onze candidats sont sur la ligne de
départ vous voyez leur donc s'afficher
un scrutin rendu nécessaire après la
démission de nadia est devenu ministre
délégué à la ville premier tour le
dimanche 20 septembre éventuel deuxième
tour le dimanche 27 septembre et parmi
les candidats à sandrine grand gambe et
en lice pour génération et europe
ecologie les verts présentation de la
candidate du conseil régional à
l'assemblée nationale c'est le chemin
qui espère parcourir sandrine grand gang
la première adjointe de la ville de
trappes est candidate au poste de député
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
une campagne tournée principalement sur
la prise de conscience de la crise
environnementale et sociale des messages
forts à porter des dés à la fois sur le
plan des politiques qui sont menées et
qui ne conviennent pas aux populations
de la circonscription et puis donc il ya
des messages d alerte au niveau du
gouvernement et nous on veut porter une
voix à la fois
fort sur l'écologie sur la solidarité et
des pratiques à mettre en avant comme
celle de l'entreprise d'insertion envie
à trappes qui recycle les appareils
électroménagers est la candidate à
visiter la structure avec son suppléant
nicolas phare et le député européen
mounir satouri d'europe écologie les
verts alliés de génération pour le
scrutin le parti souhaite rassembler
tous les écologistes pour pouvoir aller
plus fort porté un message écologiste à
l'assemblée nationale permettent à
sandrine il eut locales engagées
résolument écolo d'aller siéger à
l'assemblée nationale sarah mènera du
débat ça renforcera nos interventions
pas d'union plus large de la gauche en
revanche avec une autre candidature
celle des insoumis et communistes porté
par valérie froberger un rassemblement
et espérer en cas de second tour
les amis communistes et de la france
insoumise ont voulu se compter à part
sur cette élection là c'est leur droit
je pense que c'est dommage mais je reste
optimiste sur le fait que nous avons
vocation à nous rassembler de toute
façon si elle est élue députée sandrine
grand groupe devra renoncer à l'un de
ses mandats locaux pour se conformer à
la loi
elle a indiqué qu'elle renoncerait à son
siège de conseillère régionale pour
garder son ancrage à trappes autres
candidats qui est avec moi en plateau
olivier galland bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes en lice pour deux bouts la france
avec florence bernard comme suppléante
vous êtes habitants de saint cyr l'école
depuis quinze ans vous étiez notamment
engagé dans l'associatif dans des
associations de parents d'élèves et en
2017 vous avez décidé de rejoindre
debout la france
vous êtes d'ailleurs le délégué de la
11e circonscription pour debout la
france dans les yvelines vous étiez
présent au 30ème position lors des
municipales sur la liste de sonia bros
la mère élue à saint cyr l'école
pourquoi cet engagement récent en
politique et pourquoi être candidat pour
ce scrutin alors l'engagement c'est le
hasard
je me suis présenté à une réunion de la
france ça m'a plu je suis resté le poste
de délégué de l'ancienne circonscription
est devenu vacant
on me l'a proposé et puis aujourd'hui le
hasard de dd ministère fait que sur
l'ancienne circonscription où on va pour
des législatives
c'est chez moi donc je me suis
normalement présenter
occasion qui s'est présentée debout la
france compte un seul député à
l'assemblée nationale nicolas dupont
aignan dont on reparlera tout à l'heure
ce qu'il était ce matin dans les
yvelines pourquoi debout la france
doit-il compter un député supplémentaire
à l'assemblée nationale quelle
conviction il faut porter à l'assemblée
nationale selon vous quelles sont les
conditions du parti nous avons des
convictions fortes sur sur la
souveraineté de la france à nous sommes
des souverainistes
nous avons une volonté de rendre notre
pays plus sûr de lutter contre
l'insécurité de lutter contre contre les
fraudes et de rendre notre pays plus
agréable à nos concitoyens
d'ailleurs si on revient sur les trois
axes de votre candidature sur cette 11e
circonscription est effectivement la
lutte contre les trafics de drogue
l'autorité de l'état la justice sociale
ça c'est les trois priorités de cette
campagne pour vous ce sont 3,3 priorités
sur lesquelles nous mettrons l'accent
ces deux ce sont des choses sur les
contre lesquels nous voulons lutter
parce qu'on estime que le gouvernement
actuel ne fait pas ne fait pas ce qu'il
faut
après on en reparlera un petit peu mais
on dit si tout ce qu'on n'aime pas par
contre il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
apprécie et qu'on va voir dans le
reportage un petit peu après juste un
petit mot sur la députée précédente qui
a démissionné n'en dirai comment vous
jugez ces trois ans de mandat comme
député de la 11e circonscription
écoutez moi je les ai je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup dans la circonscription je ne
sais pas si elle est venue sur sur saint
cyr l'école tout cas elle a fait
quelques quelques actions quelques
apparitions à l'assemblée mais ça ne
nous a pas marqué alors dans le cadre de
cette campagne vous avez reçu le soutien
aujourd'hui sur le terrain de nicolas
dupont-aignan le président de debout la
france le député de l'essonne s'est
rendu on va le voir avec vous ce matin
au haras de du centaure c'est à bailly
c'est à proximité directe de saint cyr
l'école va peut-être voir les images et
s'afficher non ça c'est un meeting
précédent de nicolas dupont aignan voilà
les images qui s'affiche alors sortir
l'école c'est l'une des sept communes de
la circonscription c'est un déplacement
ce matin qui était sur le thème de la
violence contre les équidés plus de 150
faits ont été recensés en france 5 dans
les yvelines et nicolas dupont aignan
demande au gouvernement un
renforcement des sanctions contre les
auteurs de ces maltraitances
ecoutez-le c'était au micro de mélanie
poker je ne peux pas comprendre comment
des personnes peuvent s'introduire dans
des haras et égorgé des animaux et se
livraient des actes de barbarie donc
j'aimerais qu'on comprenne et pour
comprendre il faut les trouver
et donc je demande au gouvernement de
mettre les enquêteurs nécessaire c'est
une question de moyens et il faut cibler
pour enfin en finir parce qu'on ne peut
pas continuer comme ça il faut qu'on
trouve
quelles sont ces malades ou ces barbares
et pourquoi ils font ça et qu'ils soient
sanctionnés pour que les éleveurs de
chevaux puis zich tranquille olivier
galland aujourd'hui les auteurs de ces
sévices graves et actes de cruauté
envers les animaux encourt jusqu'à deux
ans de prison et 30000 euros d'amendé il
faut aller plus loin selon vous c'est un
texte pourquoi pas apporté au sein de
l'assemblée nationale alors peut-être
qu'il faut qu'il faut augmenter les
sanctions contre tous ceux qui
permettent de maltraiter les animaux
aujourd'hui les lois existent mais elles
ne sont pas appliquées les sanctions qui
sont qui sont mises contre contre moi je
dis c'est barbare mais contre ces
personnes ne sont pas appliquées
peut-être qu'ils vont s'en sortir avec
un simple rappel à la loi on n'en sait
rien en tout cas la justice
aujourd'hui on la trouve un petit peu
trop laxiste alors que les lois existent
les lois existent
appliquons les appliquons laisse
sévèrement sur des faits graves ce que
demandait effectivement nicolas dupont
aignan si on parle de la campagne
forcément un peu particulière avec le le
contexte du coronavirus est-ce que c'est
difficile d'aller à la rencontre des
électeurs il ya le masque à cette
barrière du masque est ce que c'est
c'est difficile plus difficile je crois
que non vous savez quand on quand on va
frapper chez les gens ils n'ont pas leur
masque sur eux ils eux mêmes même dans
cette dans ce contexte de co vide
les gens reprennent prennent un peu de
liberté et de chez eux ne porte pas le
masque donc on va les voir discuter avec
eux on a le masque où on a pas mais on
est accueilli avec un grand sourire
en plus c'est une première campagne pour
vous donc vous n'êtes pas forcément de
de comparaison de comparatifs avec
d'autres d'autres campagnes
alors j'ai milité dans le cadre des
européennes et donc j'ai été voir les
jours un petit peu partout j'ai fait du
militantisme et on avait le même accueil
les gens sont heureux qu'on aille les
voir et qu'on s'intéresse à un
territoire où l'on vote peu pardon moins
d'un électeur sur deux s'était déplacée
aux urnes en 2017
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire
aux électeurs il ya forcément si ce
contexte particulier avec on le disait
le contexte sanitaire on est en pleine
rentrée allaient voter allez voter pour
cette législative partielle c'est pas
forcément peut-être la priorité numéro
un des habitants de cette 11e
circonscription
c'est bien possible le contexte
sanitaire on l'a vu dans les municipales
avec un taux d'abstention qui était qui
était assez fort on craint d'avoir la
même chose lors de cette élection
une forte abstention alors on ne sait
pas encore si c'est parce que les
électeurs ne sont pas vraiment encore au
courant qu'il ya une élection dimanche
prochain ou si c'est dans le contexte du
coc vide mais une forte abstention et
prévisible alors on discute et puis on
dit aux gens qui en tout cas pas tant de
risques que ça le des mesures sanitaires
sont prises et par contre on peut pas se
plaindre de la situation actuelle et ne
pas aller voter
la démocratie ça nous permet de nous
exprimer donc profitons de ce droit que
nous avons
merci olivier galland d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
candidat de debout la france pour cette
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines premier
tour programmé ce dimanche dimanche 20
septembre et l'ensemble des candidats
auront l'occasion de débattre de leurs
idées au cours d'un débat qui sera
diffusé ce jeudi sur tv 78 voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi ne manquez pas je vous le rappelle
ce rendez vous dans un instant le retour
du 7-8 culture c'est à partir de 18h30
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]